is hurry because I'm here to answer your
misconception yeah I don't want you to
think that Alice here to kill you
consider this believe Donna I have no
problem if I saw anybody touching you in
this pub I'll be the first to defend you
understand this doesn't that go against
the whole principle the Quran if you're
a disbeliever say I'll kill kill him I
will defend you no no no I hope I go
against any kind of violence I don't
believe there's any violence verses in
the Quran that so exact innocent people
no good right so okay now we've talked
about different topic now you clean
something yeah can you show me this
verse that talks about killing of
innocent people
okay but then why you making statements
if you're not sure no me Charlotte why
is this - 1 9 1 yeah
okay can you go to just do this yeah
just give them context to 1 9 0 okay
McKesson surprise continue so continue
so so what about CeCe what about what we
see okay good yeah now read it for me
yeah I'm cool auntie one-on-one and kill
them wherever you overtake me and expel
and expel them forever they have
expelled you and is worth is worse than
killing if it lies disbelief right
you've won one translation means nothing
there's a few there can be corruption in
the land it's the current with you
can you open your medians not killing
194 yeah okay
so so now what I'm speaking to you by
the area no no no you've read that verse
now we're gonna give a context to it
yeah
and I'm you know you know what's can
happen here you're gonna agree with this
verse you're gonna caddy 170 with this
verse you are understanding and agree
with it which we cannot go
okay listen verse yeah let's read it
together you fight in the way of Allah
against those who fight against you stop
if I come to attack you what do you do
that
you're a terrorist you're a terrorist
why didn't work at that fight in the way
of Allah against don't fight you so it's
not at the Bible you don't have like 500
different versions you fight in the way
of Allah against those who fight you
okay why do you let me speak my freedom
of speech fights in the way of Allah
against Ozzy fight you what do you
understand from them no you're presuming
this I'm asking something yet if I said
you hurry fight Jason the way he fought
you would you gather fights in the way
of Allah against those who fight you but
look look look look look guys guys
please be the reason forgive you hurry
by the way if I come across aggressive
forgive me because you want you want to
dialogue with you I long had to live in
harmony okay fight in the way of Allah
against those who fight you now them
automatically what we get from this is
that unless a fight them the way find a
fight did you defend yourself but begin
not hostilities what does that mean you
do not be the trend racers you be not
the ones that fight them first
Allah loves not the trunk racers now
even even kaffir
yeah the GCTF the the event of a test it
is but when he's talking about
translation is talking about for example
abu bakr radiallahu under the companions
of the prophet said when you go to war i
have 10 commandments for you do not harm
innocent woman children babies animals
cheese please notes so
yes let me tell them they don't you
can't force them Allah says in the Quran
there is no compulsion in religion
meaning I cannot face you man having the
space I don't know okay so one second
moment so therefore in the exegesis yeah
it even compared he says that when Allah
talks about translation is saying that
in no way shape or form when you go to
the battlefield you find the enemies
that fight you so he's talking about
this believers because those who were
fighting them you know I never find the
Muslims because they believed in God and
they believed in Islam that's the only
reason so Allah says here do not be
hostile
do not run dress yeah so can we both
agree that you can defend yourself and
you should not be the first person
that's attacking you
so now what I see see now now we're
gonna go to the next verse here we both
agree on 119 context yeah so now the
deceit deceive you're talking about in
the Bible where Jesus is - I don't know
one second now let's go back to the
Western will tell me what you don't
agree with do you agree to one ninety
the defend yourself and do not be the
stronger so let's go to this let's go to
the next verse
hurry yeah these guys hate preachers No
we know them for the past three four
years the only reason they're here is
because they know this video is going to
reach thousands of people so now I'm
gonna go to verse 191 yeah yeah
and slay them wherever you find them and
listen carefully
yes miss believers who were attacking
the Muslims come check this out and slay
them wherever you find them thanking you
yeah okay now did you see that
disgusting Islamic Wow hates me
these people the true quality well
anyways guys guys now look at this here
look how do I get debunks and slay them
what was it and slay them wherever you
find them listen very carefully and
drive them out of the places once they
drove you out stop a second now what
does this mean drive them out kick them
out from where they kicked you out so if
I come and say to you you know how from
your house I wish I wish they'd only
kick me on the house you do you what the
[ __ ] is that their companies will
being tortured it's one of the female
companion now and slay them so way says
yeah drag them out from where they drove
you out for persecution is worse than
slaughter yes and fight them not with
inviting a place of worship
they first attack you there so you can
clearly see you can clearly see the over
here buddy scene they've kicked you off
from your houses get your houses back
and kick them out that is justice nice
fair that is justice I'm sorry
there is nobody nobody nobody no no no
it's not violence it's defending
yourself defending yourself cuz I will
say to you are you a fighter for
defending yourself defending yourself
that's what I'm seeing you here it says
because they're coming to attack my wife
you have to fight them my wife you have
to fight them to gain your house back so
now and fight not with them in the
invaluable places of worship untrue they
attack you there first or now this is a
commission do you not fight them there
until they attack you first but if they
attack you there then say them such as a
reward for this believers now when I
losses disbelievers it's not talking
about you is no it's not my you once
again did you come here and say I'm
gonna chop your head off against each
other argument as we speak yeah as we
speak with unscripted Nia here when you
go to war you have to be deluded or
pacifist and people think that when you
go to war that's going to be all
hunky-dory it's not so here in the
second verse it makes it clear the
verses are attacking who are non-muslims
not Muslim
non-muslims document because of their
freedom of speech of believe in their
religion but if they desist then Allah
is forgiving merciful look at this no no
no if they are merciful to the believers
Muslims so here the Prophet Muhammad for
10 years goes on the persecution these
people are coming to attack all terminal
of my scene if they desist if they stop
fighting you Allah loves is most
forgiving most merciful can you imagine
if I persecuted you and your family for
ten years and I stopped fighting you
would you still come after me would you
let me go imagine a few job your your
family your sister your brother your mom
and for ten years I say you know I'm
gonna stop fighting you would you be
calm or would you want revenge if you
say in the Quran so if I killed your
family for ten years I'm securing your
family I'm torching there I've killed
your family members and then one day I
say you know what that's enough I don't
know I'm gonna I'm gonna leave you alone
yeah would you leave me alone after that
it's tough that poor fool well if if you
if you turn that in in the turns the
Quran thank you
so therefore what is what is Allah see
[Music]
you said Allah says if they stop
fighting you unless forgive them most
merciful leave them
now we both does that mean it is money
it's saying that in terms of if they'd
submit to Allah no look this is but if
they desist is talking about
it's believed final answer no no no no
this verse is talking about from
sneaking the Battle of mother yeah he's
talking about the aggressors that are
attacking and Allah saying defend
yourself if they fight you fight them
back do not fight them first
do not run rest you knock your men women
and children if they stop fighting you
unless forgiving merciful Allah will
forgive ya ok so all I'm asking you is
to have an open mind because I'm here to
answer misconception I don't want you to
think that led to kill you consider this
[Music]
anybody touching you in this pub I'll be
the first to defend if you leave I'll
kill kill him I will defend you on
teníamos of camera I swear to God if
anybody touched you on justy I will
defend you nobody can touch him from now
if you feel comfortable Muslim these
Muslims around us and stuff that I hear
ok and fight on to fight them on to
persecution is no more so unless they
invite them to they stop the persecution
yeah and you know we could agree that
for example these demon guns do you not
believe that we should stop them with
the acts that they doing yeah
so this is what it is a prosecution has
happened against young girls we should
be in the forefront fighting them I'm on
camera in the best way for Sevilla in no
physical way just stop them from doing
their act
yeah and the religion is for Allah but
if they desist then let there be no
hostility except against wrongdoers so
I'm a senior Congress and lastly the
last verse the forbidden month for the
forbidden month and forbidden things in
retaliation and Isis you know why I'm
here
for example there is no way in the Quran
that would justify that they do because
you know why the whole definition of
this is what attack them
no they attacked you yeah so that
meaning in Islam is forbidden you cannot
kill innocent men women children babies
look we can no harm trees man let alone
human life which is more sacred so here
allah is saying attacked in the way of
they ever touch you yeah so this did you
say that they they they argue that the
the West
are the transgressors okay good so why
is the problem of Isis the foreign
policy know something the way they you
know how to justify it they say these
people America and Britain have come to
our country and blew up our brothers and
sisters and children we're gonna do the
same back to them wrong you know why
because it says
Allah says in the Quran that translation
what this truncation mean that
translation is in the turf Silverman
kefir is that you are not allowed to in
home innocent people period you cannot
so there is no way these Isis guys get
it from the Quran no way the only thing
they do is a lakh worth man that's like
me having a bacon sandwich and saying
about making permissible I still I still
I still stand there and if I can say
that even even even with the context of
that that verse yeah they they could
justify violence no by by any means
there's no way for pizza foreign policy
no no no argue as you make your argument
is that it's the foreign policy that say
no no I'm saying if there's one thing
they're gonna hold don't you is the
foreign policy there is no way they're
gonna come and say in the Quran it tells
us to do this this this nonsense they're
emotional people you have seen people
get blown up and they say we're gonna do
the same back to them sorry but no
whoever's doing that they know our
teachers we follow the Quran not the
ones you are killing us dream jealousy
so nowhere in the Quran of us is
determined Robinson he wrote a whole
book how could you know give one verse
in the whole bloody book yeah not book
unless I admire you that you have
brought a misconception detention
nowhere in the Quran I challenge anybody
to show me a single verse clearly says
one clearly go and kill the disbelievers
just because they're disbelievers
nonsense no way hurry no way it teaches
I want you to know that very sure to me
that it doesn't and show me if it does